(dramatic music)
- Okay, this is it.
Any questions?
Everybody knows what
they're doing, right?
'Cause we got one shot at this.
There's no dumb
questions, you guys.
Did you have a question?
No?
So all of you guys know
exactly what your job is?
Okay, so on my count.
Three, two, one.
Go, go, go, go!
(all shouting and grunting)
Unbelievable.
♪ But I don't need you ♪
(suspenseful music)
(window tapping)
- Was I speeding, officer?
- You don't look like
you from around here.
- No, sir.
- You've been doing
any drugs tonight?
- No, sir.
- Nope?
- No.
- Why don't you pop that trunk,
step out of the
vehicle for me, please.
- Really?
- No drugs, huh?
- Nope.
- Well, well, well,
what have we here?
- No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You planted that in my car.
- Oh, did I?
Or did I plant this?
- Uh, I guess...
- Against the car, right now.
Spread 'em!
Whoa, whoa, what do
we have here, huh?
- What?
- These your colors, homie?
- That's not mine.
- Huh?
- Uh, no.
- I don't know--
- Or are these your colors?
Or perhaps these
are your colors.
Or are these, look
at all these colors.
Man, you sure got
a lot of colors.
Look at all of these colors.
What's up?
- Are you a real cop?
- Freeze!
What is that?
Hm.
Well, well, well, it looks
like an illegal firearm.
Or, is it?
- Oh.
I don't, I don't know
what this is, I'm sorry.
- Pick a card.
- It's not even a good fan.
- Any card.
You can just stick, there.
Okay, you took that card.
- Yeah.
- Now can you
remember that card?
- Yes.
- Can you commit
that card to memory?
- This is unbelievable.
- Have you done so?
Have you done so?
- Yes!
- Please insert the card
back into the deck randomly.
- Done.
- It's in a different place
than where you
took it originally?
There we are, there we are.
- This is ridiculous.
- I take the deck like so.
I give it a skasloicles.
And abrakasroice.
(gun booming)
Okay.
Is this your card?
- No!
- Are you sure?
- I want your badge
number. (coughing)
- Oh, oh.
- What the?
It's my card.
How did you do that?
- And that is for you.
- After all that, you're
still giving me a ticket?
- Is it a ticket, or is
it a two for one coupon
for my show at The Magic House,
Thursday night at 11:00 PM.
Your call.
- I'll take the ticket.
- Freeze, police!
Hands up.
Turn around slowly.
Okay, buddy.
Do not move a muscle
Up, up.
Get your hands back up.
No, raise them up.
Hands up, now!
No, no, stop.
I said no moving.
Put your foot down.
That's good.
Now easy does it.
No, don't pick
your other foot up.
Put that down.
Put your foot down.
There we go.
No, do not pick
the other one up.
Put that one down.
Put your foot down.
No, not, put them
both down at the same.
Okay, now you're just walking.
Stop walking, now!
No walking.
I want you to stop
walking right now.
Do not get near that car.
Wait, get away from it.
No, don't go near that car.
Don't open that door.
Do not open that door!
Don't open it.
Do not open the car door!
Don't you open that door!
Don't.
Do not get in that car.
Freeze.
Your butt better
not hit that seat.
Okay, stay, get out of there.
Get out of the car right now.
No you don't.
Don't you dare reach for
that glove compartment.
Don't reach for that
glove compartment!
glove compartment.
Get your hand away from
the glove compartment.
Don't you open it!
Do not grab that gun.
Whatever you do, dude, you
better not grab that gun.
You better not grab that gun.
Do not pull that gun on me.
Put that down!
Don't you pull that gun on me.
No, hey, put that down.
Don't do it!
Dammit, God dammit!
(dramatic music)
Dammit, not again.
- This is all about Susie Diaz.
It's Susie Diaz's party.
Susie Diaz is running the show.
I'm just gonna show up.
If she needs me to
bring beer or something,
I'm more than happy to do...
Oh, dude.
Oh my God.
A woman just fainted.
I'm gonna have to call you back.
Ma'am.
(dynamic music)
Oh, um.
(phone beeping)
(phone ringing)
- 9-1-1, what is your emergency?
- Yes, yeah, I'm the corner
of 5th and Metropolitan.
And I just came
across this woman,
and she just passed out
on the sidewalk here.
- Okay, and is she
responsive, sir?
- Um.
(dramatic music)
- Okay, sir, is she responsive?
Sir, sir?
- Um, no.
- [Operator] Sir,
if you can hear me.
- She's not responsive.
She's beautiful.
- That is not relevant
to this emergency, sir.
An ambulance is on its way.
In the meantime, I need you
to check her pulse, sir.
- Check her pulse, right?
Check her pulse, okay.
- Does she have a pulse, sir?
- She does, but her
skin is so soft.
- Sir.
- She doesn't have
on a ton of makeup,
but she's the kind of girl
that just doesn't need it.
- Sir.
- You can see that she put a
lot of thought into her outfit,
but not like she's
trying too hard.
She's perfect.
- Sir, may I remind you
that you have not spoken
a word to this woman?
I need you to see
if she's breathing.
- If she's breathing, yeah,
okay, hold on. (dramatic music)
- Sir, I need you
to stay on track.
- Hold on.
Oh God, she's not breathing.
The love of my life
is not breathing.
You gotta save my baby!
- Do you know how to give
mouth to mouth resuscitation?
- Yes, I do.
- Okay, I need you to
administer that now.
- Okay, okay.
No, no, I can't, I can't do it.
I can't, I can't do it.
It's just, it's disrespectful.
I have to be respectful for her.
- Sir, this is the
only time it's okay
to put your mouth on
an unconscious woman.
Do it.
- I just didn't picture
it happening this way.
There's butterflies in my
stomach and I'm just, (gasping)
I don't wanna mess this
up. It's so rare to find...
- Sir, if you can hear me,
an ambulance is on its way.
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- I need you to calm down.
- Oh gosh, my head.
- Sir, stay with me.
- This is what it feels
like to be in love.
- [Operator] Stay with me, sir.
- It must feel like
when you find the one.
- Sir?
(phone beeping and buzzing)
(dynamic music)
(phone beeping and ringing)
9-1-1, what is your emergency?
- There's an attractive,
confident, well to do Black man.
He just passed out right
here on the street.
- Okay ma'am, listen
very carefully.
I'm going to need
you to marry him.
- Oh, okay.
Shouldn't I give him like
mouth to mouth first?
- Yeah, girl, get you some.
Shoot.
(engine rumbling)
(suspenseful music)
- This is 288.
I'm investigating a
report of a disturbance.
- [Man] Roger that, 288.
- Freeze!
- Because I got a popsicle you--
- Gun!
(gun booming)
(dramatic music)
Oh rats!
- Whoa.
- Watch out, that
Black guy's got a gun!
He's gonna steal your banana!
- [Both] What?
(officer yelling)
(gun booming)
- Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go
go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, come on.
Sir, you're gonna have
to leave the area,
there's been a disturbance.
Go, for your safety, sir.
Go now, please.
Okay, go, go, go, get going.
(officer yells)
Big fuzzy gun!
(officer yelling)
(gun booming)
- I mean, it was like a
holiday for people having guns.
- God dammit!
Mayor's on a warpath.
Who's responsible for this mess?
- I'm sorry, Chief, it was me.
Gun!
(officer yelling)
(gun booming)
God dammit!
Coffee cup.
My bad.
Anyway, the last seven
came outta nowhere.
- What flavor you got?
- Vanilla.
What flavor you got?
- Lemon zinger.
- Lemon zinger like that tea?
- Oh.
Oh no.
- What's going on?
- I got that brain freeze.
- Oh man, the (beeps) you do.
You ain't got no brain freeze.
- Ooh!
- Dude, relax man.
That (beeps) gonna pass, man.
Calm down.
- It ain't passing. (groans)
It's intensifying.
- It's not passing?
It can't be intensifying, dog.
Come on, man. You said
you from the hood, dog.
You acting weak right now
with this brain freeze.
(man groaning)
Come on.
Ain't no brain freeze gonna
make you yell like that, man.
Get over-- Don't be hitting
your head with the brain freeze.
Come on, it ain't.
You going silver balls on it?
Silver balls and a
straight kinetic energy.
What's wrong with you?
Come on.
Okay, Exorcist.
What are you doing now?
What you doing, some Kung Fu?
Get over it, man.
Listen, it can't be
doing this much to you.
Listen man, don't be
a punk ass bitch, man.
Get over the brain--
What, you afraid now?
You seeing things?
You just scared? The brain
freeze making you scared.
- Who are you?
- What do you mean, who am I?
You ain't got no Alzheimer's,
what's wrong with you.
(man shrieking)
You a punk-ass bitch.
What is this?
You going all Three
Stooges on this (beeps).
This is some craziness.
Oh, you did the hand block.
You know what, man,
you're weak, man.
You're a weak-ass (beeps).
That's the problem.
'Cause you're pud.
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo,
yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Hold up now, hold up now,
hold up now, hold up now.
Hold up, man. You gonna
continue to eat the fro yo,
even on top of the brain freeze?
What you doing, dog?
Hey, now I'm really start
to respect you now, man
If you gonna eat the thing
that's causing you the pain.
This is crazy.
Oh, now it's going faster.
He's speeding up.
He steering into
the brain freeze.
This (beeps) is straight
crazy right here, dog.
Hey, real talk though, real
talk though, real talk though.
I mean, this crazier
than the time, man,
that I strangled Benny
with my bare hands
'cause he didn't have my money.
- All right, we got him.
- Got who?
What?
What you 5-0?
- [Man] Stand up, slowly.
- Who?
I can't believe this.
Man, I've known you
since sixth grade.
- You under arrest for the
murder of Benny Tagtheratrix.
Get him outta here.
- Man, you a punk-ass
brain freeze (beeps).
- You going to jail for
a long time. (groans)
I'm in too deep.
Ah, I got the brain freeze.
Got caught with
the brain freeze.
- [Man] Yeah you got
that brain freeze.
- Get him outta here.
(funky music)
♪ All I want, yeah ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪